protect your bubble calm proud sponsors
of swipe on Sky News you're watching
swipe on this show this week smells like
screen spirits the cinema are taking aim
at all five of your senses record
breakers Apple makes huge profits at the
end of 2014 and crime-solving skeletons
time-travel and zombies we've got it all
in our games review hello and welcome to
thrive this week we're at the UK's
first-ever 4dx cinema we've all heard of
2d and 3d movies that 4dx
takes it a step further its makers claim
it's a totally immersive experience the
seats move you can get hit by wind and
rain and you can even smell what's going
on on screen here's to it
if sights and sounds just aren't enough
for you when you head to the cinema how
about this it's called 4d X seats that
move around air water and fog effects
all synchronized to the action on screen
even smells are on the menu from flower
shop to - a white gardenia Coffee
raspberry burning rubber gun smoke test
them badges opening the valve and then
you'll smell the coffee smell coming out
of there which is pumped straight
through to the auditorium 4dx was
developed by a South Korean cinema chain
and made its debut in 2009 one of the
first films to utilize it was Avatar the
technology has spread to more than 20
countries and now it's arrived in the UK
with the seats we can start with by
making them all roll around a bit so you
can see that's happening then on the
seat effects we can do whatever we want
so we can have a bit of face water a bit
of face air so you start that and all
this can happen all at the same time and
all timed in with the movie probably the
most important question here
do you want this kind of experience at
the cinema how you answer that will
determine where the 4dx can be a true
success or if it's dismissed as a
gimmick I really like all the stuff like
the stroboscopic lights and the smoke
coming out of the screen and the the
mist and things like that
I do find out you with the chair wall
boys but it's so intense that you almost
find yourself distracted from the image
to some extent you sort of find yourself
more focus on what's happening to your
body than what's actually in front of
your eyes there's also the cost to
consider if you want to watch a film at
this new screen in Milton Keynes
complete with splashes fog lightning and
a moving chair it'll cost you from 13 to
15 pounds depending on whether the movie
is in 2d or 3d I think it lends itself
to certain types of films and those big
blockbuster films with lots of action
will really do well out of something
like this this combines everything from
maybe the theme park action through to a
cinema going experience and I think
that's really exciting I don't think it
will become the norm across all cinemas
but it's definitely a nice added value
at the moment films aren't being made
with 4dx in mind the effects are bolted
on to existing movies just like 3d and
IMAX that could change directors could
one day have a hand in targeting all
five of our senses well we didn't come
all this way just to let you have all
the fun this time I had to go as well
okay let's watch something let's do it
so what are these these are 3d glasses
let's start the effects but hang on am I
going to get wet yes of course good but
can I opt to not hook it's quite cold
can I opt to not have the wet there's a
little button here to turn it off yes
please
a Roman you bringing out the dearest no
yes you are
somebody just walk me through what we
supposed to be doing
it is it is so you've got wind effect up
there
I think we go
you can but so we advise not to bring
hot drinks oh that's the water again Oh
a great experience fantastic thank you
for showing me that it was a bit like a
roller coaster quite exhausting and I'm
a little bit annoyed that you turn my
water back on oh well you know I wanted
you to have the full effect what I
suddenly got that but over they'll dry
off soon thanks a lot
you're watching swype coming up life is
strange turn back the clock in our games
review but first here's a roundup of
some of this week's other tech stories
what a week it's been for Apple the
company announced it had made the
biggest profit in corporate history
nearly twelve billion pounds in the
final three months of last year the
boost was largely driven by sales of the
latest iPhone a card game called
exploding kittens has become the most
backed Kickstarter project ever don't
worry it doesn't cause any actual harm
to cats
the makers call it a kitty powered
version of Russian Roulette and say they
received 100% funding in just 20 minutes
on the crowdfunding platform the Google
Lunar XPrize competition to land a
private spacecraft on the moon is
hotting up five of the teams from around
the world competing to win have been
awarded a milestone prize a combined sum
of nearly three and a half million
pounds for the progress in innovation
they've made so far they've got until
the end of next year to attempt the trip
now I'm not gonna lie to you we've got
some pretty heavy stuff in this
games review survival horror epic sci-fi
battles and time travel we don't worry
we've thrown in a talking cartoon
skeleton to lighten the mood and Cameron
Robinson is going to hold our hands
throughout so if you've been playing
video games for a long time you will
know the name grim fandago it's an
absolute classic kind of film noir dark
comedies tale and you play a chap called
Manny Calavera and it's a hilarious
story you basically our travel agent in
the Land of the Dead
so you have kind of put people on these
various trips and but you can have in
like a dead-end job but the big thing
you notice is how hard it is the puzzles
are really tricky and the game doesn't
hold your hand so that's something
that's really changed in videogames
nowadays there's so much more hints and
tips there's none of that there's still
none of that
but what's remastered well it looks much
better the characters look beautiful and
is almost dynamic lighting but if you've
never played Grim Fandango then now is
the perfect time to do so can get on
PlayStation on your pizza and on PC as
well so dying light is arguably the
biggest game coming out this week and I
know you're thinking do we really need
another zombie game and well maybe we do
it's a bit different from other zombie
games actually offers something with two
things in fact that are quite exciting
so first off he's inclined like pretty
much anything there's a whole parkour
aspect into the games you can jump
around the rooftops because actually
when the town is you know infested with
zombies the rooftops probably the safest
place to be but the other big difference
about it is it's got an active day/night
cycle so that means time literally
passes by and what happens is at
nighttime everything changes the zombies
get a lot more difficult and dangerous
so you have to like sneak about you kind
of become the hunted but if this sounds
like your cup of tea and you can stomach
yet another zombie game it's definitely
worth checking out so life is strange is
something genuinely interesting coming
out in the world of video games this
this week for a couple of reasons first
off it's a single-player adventure with
a female lead which is all too rare in
the video games industry so you play as
Max and she's a teenage girl has gone
back to what used to be her home town
she
way in there she's back many years later
as a teenager and she's got this power
to rewind time and that's the kind of
key mechanic in this whole video game
the way the gameplay is different from
everything else is this time mechanic so
often in games where you have to make a
decision you make a decision and then
those consequences are there for the
rest of the game you can replay the game
to see what the other decisions might
have been but in this game you don't
have to you can make a decision see how
that goes then rewind it and make
another one so that sounds like your cup
of tea should check it out
[Music]
well that's it for this week don't
forget you can stay up to date with all
the latest tech stories on Tiny's for
iPad or smartphone apps Dainese calm and
our youtube channel but for now i'm
going to take on the full experience
[Applause]
[Music]
protect your bubble comm proud sponsors
of swipe on sky news